MALE SPEAKER: So today we're
here to see Jerry Kaplan.
He's co-founded four
startups, two of which
have gone public-- serial
entrepreneur, widely
respected as a
technical innovator,
and a bestselling author.
In the interest of
time though, I'm
going to abridge his long
list of many accomplishments
and talk about a few things
that I think will especially
interest you before he talks
about things that especially
interest him.
So one especially interesting
thing that he's done-- he
was the co-founder, alongside
his friends Kevin Doren
and Robert Carr, of the
GO Corporation in 1987.
They were pioneers in the work
of tablet and stylus-based
computing, the precursors to the
Apple Newton, the Palm Pilot,
and later smartphones
and tablets of today.
If you chronicled,
actually, his time there,
they have a very interesting
book called "Startup:
The Silicon Valley Adventure."
Some of you may
have heard of this.
A fun little fact.
Omid Kordestani-- some
of you may know him
as our former chief
business officer, started
at Google in 1999-- got his
start, actually, at Go Corp.
Jerry may talk about that.
I don't know.
It's possible.
Here he is today again to talk
about artificial intelligence
and the changing world
of work automation.
So we are here for
"Humans Need Not Apply."
Give a warm welcome to
Jerry Kaplan, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
JERRY KAPLAN: Thanks,
how's the mic?
Oh, that's good.
All right, well, a mentor
of mine used to say never
give a talk the first time.
I want you to know
I've put together
a special talk for you guys.
This is the first I'm giving it.
We'll see what happens.
I should leave some time.
I have lots of weird
anecdotes about Google
that I will be happy to tell
when I'm not on the camera,
as long as I'm not
being recorded.
OK, so now for something
completely different, as
they used to say
on "Monty Python."
The common wisdom about
artificial intelligence
is that we're building
increasingly intelligent
machines that are
ultimately going
to surpass human capabilities
and steal our jobs
and maybe even
escape human control
and take over the world.
So I'm going to
present the case today
that that narrative
is both misguided and
counterproductive-- that a
more appropriate way to frame
this, which is really
better supported
by actual historical
and current events,
is that AI is simply
a natural extension
of long-standing efforts to
automate tasks that date back
at least to the start of
the Industrial Revolution.
And then I want to talk
about the consequences
if you think about it
in that particular way.
But let me ask about the
audience-- how many of you
are engineers?
OK, how many of you
are not engineers?
Two.
How many people haven't
raised their hand yet?
Nobody.
OK.
And that's called
closure, right?
OK, and how many of
you are doing anything
even vaguely related to AI?
Oh, not that many, OK.
Cool.
At least you won't admit it by
the time I'm done with my talk,
I think.
OK, so let me start with a
little bit of a history lesson.
I'm teaching Impact of
Artificial Intelligence
at Stanford.
And much to my
shock, the students
who studied artificial
intelligence
don't know much
about its history.
So here's a kind
of irreverent view.
I'm going to start with an
unorthodox history of AI.
Now, here's a news
flash for you.
Science does not
proceed scientifically.
So it's like the making of
legislation and sausage.
Perhaps this is better done
outside of the public view.
More than you might
want to believe,
progress is often due
to the clash of egos
and ideas and institutions.
You guys work in an institution.
I'm sure you see
that occasionally.
And artificial intelligence
is no exception,
so let me start right
at the beginning.
Dartmouth College, 1956.
A group of scientists--
they got together
for an extended working session.
How many of you who
John McCarthy is?
Oh, man, OK.
He's a mathematician who was
then employed at Dartmouth.
Now, he hosted this meeting
along with-- raise your hand
if you know these
guys-- Marvin Minsky.
Oh, more than John, OK.
He was then at Harvard.
Claude Shannon?
That's good.
You guys should
know who Shannon is.
He was at Bell Laboratories.
And Nathaniel Rochester?
Probably no hands.
One hand.
Are you his son?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JERRY KAPLAN: OK, there you go.
He was at IBM.
Now, here's what
these guys had to say,
or John McCarthy had to say.
He called his
proposal "A Proposal
for the Dartmouth
Summer Research Project
on Artificial Intelligence."
Now, this was the first known
use of the term artificial
intelligence.
But what's not commonly known
is why did John McCarthy choose
that particular name?
He explained this
later-- much later,
actually-- his motivation.
He said, "As for myself,
one of the reasons
for inventing the term
artificial intelligence
was to escape the
association with cybernetics.
Its concentration on analog
feedback seemed misguided,
and I wished to
avoid having either
to accept Norbert
Wiener as a guru
or having to argue with him."
Now, Norbert Wiener,
as you may know,
was a highly respected--
Norbert Wiener?
Anybody?
Oh, my god.
OK.
Cybernetics.
Good, you've heard
the term at least.
He was a highly respected
senior mathematician
and a philosopher at MIT.
Now, while he was that,
McCarthy, this guy,
was just a junior
professor at Dartmouth.
So he didn't want to have to go
up against the powers that be.
So to understand the original
intention of the founding
fathers of AI,
it's worth reading
some of the actual text of
this conference proposal.
I think it's on the screen.
"The study is to proceed on
the basis of the conjecture
that every aspect of
learning or any other feature
of intelligence can in principle
be so precisely described
that a machine can be
made to simulate it.
An attempt will be
made to find out
how to make machines
use language,
form abstractions
and concepts, solve
kinds of problems now
reserved for humans,
and improve themselves."
It's 1950-- what was it, 1956?
"We think that a
significant advance
could be made in one or more
these problems if a carefully
selected group of scientists
work on it together
for a summer."
Now, that's a pretty dubious
agenda for a summer break.
Now, many of the Dartmouth
conference participants
had their own view about
how to best approach
artificial intelligence.
But John McCarthy's specialty
was mathematical logic.
In particular, he believed
that logical inference
was the key to, using his
words, simulated intelligence.
That's what he thought AI was.
Now, his approach, skipping
ahead quite a ways,
but his approach
eventually became
known as what's called the
physical symbol systems
hypothesis.
Anybody here have heard of that?
One.
Good man, OK, you can take
over for the rest of the talk.
Now, that was the
dominant paradigm
in the field of artificial
intelligence for the first 30
years or so after the
Dartmouth Conference.
Now, here's John McCarthy.
I'm old enough to have
known John McCarthy when
I was a postdoc at Stanford,
where he founded the Stanford
Artificial Intelligence Lab.
Now, John was definitely
a brilliant scientist.
He invented the
programming language Lisp.
Good.
And he invented the
concept of time sharing.
Not too many people know that.
But he definitely had the
mad professor thing going.
Let's see if this works.
Almost.
I'm using somebody
else's computer.
You know, he had the
wild eyes and the hair.
The guy on the right,
as you may know,
is Professor Emmett Brown,
who invented the-- what is it?
The flux capacitor time machine.
How many people know
the flux capacitor?
OK, good.
I'm just checking to make
sure this talk works.
But I'm confident that John
McCarthy, having met him,
never really expected that
his clever name emerging
field is going to
turn out to be one
of the great accidental
marketing coups of all time.
So it's not only inspired
generations of researchers,
including myself, but it
spawned a virtual industry
of science fiction and
Hollywood blockbusters and media
attention and pontificating
pundits, also including myself.
How do you name the field
something less arousing,
like logical programming,
or symbolic systems?
I doubt very many of us
would have ever heard
of the field today.
The field would
have just motored
along automating various
tasks while we marvelled
at the cleverness not of
what the creations were,
but of the engineers.
I'm getting a little
bit ahead of my story.
In any case,
McCarthy's hypothesis
that logic was the basis of
human intelligence is, at best,
questionable.
Today, in fact,
most AI researchers
have abandoned this
approach and believe
it was just plain wrong.
The symbolic system approach has
been almost entirely abandoned
in favor of generally
what's now referred
to as machine learning.
How many people here are
doing machine learning?
Good.
OK, or you certainly
know about it.
But rejecting that old approach
is throwing the baby out
with the bathwater.
Some truly important
advances in computing
came out of symbolic
systems, including
things like heuristic search
algorithms, logical problem
solvers, game players,
reasoning systems.
These were all the old approach.
And many of the results
of all that work
are in wide practical use today.
For example, formulating
driving directions-- I got
lost coming here.
I didn't know the difference
between the express lane
and the regular lane.
I thought I was
in the other one.
Take this exit.
No exit.
Laying out factories
and warehouses,
proving that complex
computer chips actually
meet their specifications-- this
all uses early AI techniques.
And I'm sure that there are
many more of these to come.
Now, did I mention
machine learning?
It's certainly the focus
of most current research,
and in some circles,
at least where I am,
it's considered a
serious candidate
for the real basis of
human intelligence.
Now, my personal opinion
is that while it's
a very powerful
technology, and it's
going to have a very
significant practical impact,
it's very unlikely to be
the computational equivalent
of the human mind.
And whatever your
view, you might
be surprised to learn a
little more about what
are the fundamental concepts
that underlie what's
called the connectionist or
neural networking approach
to machine learning came from.
There are some other approaches,
mainly in the statistical area.
So let's see.
Frank Rosenblatt,
anybody heard of him?
Wow, OK, great.
I didn't until I started
researching this.
Back in the late
1950s, John McCarthy
wasn't the only one
interested in building
intelligent machines.
There was another highly
optimistic proponent,
and that was Professor
Frank Rosenblatt
at Cornell-- another competing
prominent institution.
You've got Cornell, and
you've got Dartmouth--
and lots of people at MIT.
And Rosenblatt was intrigued
by some pioneering research
by psychologists Warren
McCulloch and Walter Pitts
at the University of Chicago.
And McCulloch and
Pitts had observed
that a network of
brain neurons could
be modeled by, of all
things, logical expressions.
So Rosenblatt got
the bright idea
to implement their ideas in
a computer program, which
he rebranded as a perceptron.
Anybody heard of perceptrons?
Oh, good.
Cool.
He built an early
version of what today,
we would call a
simple neural network.
This is the geekiest
looking guy.
He looks like he's 12 years old.
That's him.
That's his actual photo
cell array right there.
Now, he wasn't about to be
outdone by McCarthy and Minsky,
so Rosenblatt heavily promoted
his work in the popular press.
For instance, he was quoted
in "The New York Times"
in 1958 saying, the machine
that he is going to build
would be the first device
to think as the human brain.
In principle, it would be
possible to build brains
that could reproduce
themselves on an assembly line,
and which would be conscious
of their existence.
This is 1958.
The article went on
to say that the embryo
of an electronic
computer-- the embryo
computer today that
will be able to walk, talk, see,
write, reproduce itself, and be
conscious of its existence.
And here's what I love.
"It is expected to be
finished in about a year
at a cost of about $100,000."
So much for the journalistic
accuracy of "The New York
Times."
By the way, I'm usually
debating John Markoff.
He's the science writer there.
We love to beat each other.
I wish he was here.
He'd go crazy.
Now, that might seem a
little bit optimistic,
given that Rosenblatt's
demonstration included
only 400 photo cells connected
to 1,000 perceptrons, which
after 50 trials, was able
to tell whether a card had
a square marked on the right
side or on the left side.
That's what he could do.
Now, on a more
positive note, and this
is also pretty
remarkable, I can't help
but notice that
many of his wilder
prophecies in the article have
actually now become reality.
He went on to say-- listen to
this closely-- remember, 1958.
"Later, perceptrons will be able
to recognize people, call out
their names, instantly
translate speech
from one language to speech or
writing in another language."
He was right.
It only took 50 years
longer than he predicted.
OK, now, Rosenblatt's work was
well known to at least some
of the participants at
that Dartmouth Conference.
In particular, he attended the
Bronx High School of Science--
anybody here go there?
Not one, wrong coast--
with Marvin Minsky.
They were one year apart.
So they later wound up going
to these different forums
and debating each
other, promoting
their respectively
favored approaches
to artificial intelligence.
Until in 1969, Minsky,
who's now at MIT-- remember,
one guy's at Cornell,
the other guy's
at MIT-- along with a colleague
of Marvin Minsky's called
Seymour Papert,
published a book called
"Perceptrons." in which he went
to pains to discredit, somewhat
unfairly I might
add, a simplified
version of Rosenblatt's work.
Now, here's the way
science really works.
Now, Rosenblatt was unable
to mount a proper defense
for a very simple reason.
Anybody guess what it was?
He died in a boating accident
in 1971, two years later.
He couldn't defend himself.
Now, the book, however,
proved highly influential,
effectively foreclosing
funding and research
on perceptrons and
artificial neural networks
in general for
more than a decade.
So after 50 years,
which is better,
the symbolic systems approach or
the machine learning approach?
The plain fact is both
of these approaches
have different strengths
and weaknesses.
In general, symbolic
reasoning is
more appropriate
for problems that
require abstract reasoning.
And machine learning,
on the other hand,
is better for problems that
require sensory perception
or extracting patterns
from large collections
of noisy data.
So you might ask
the question, why
was the symbolic
approach dominant
in the last half of the 20th
century and machine learning
is dominant today?
The answer is fairly
simple-- the machines.
They are literally a million
times faster, cheaper,
and have a million times
more memory at the same price
as they did back then.
That's a qualitative difference.
In the early days
of AI, machines just
weren't powerful enough
to automatically learn
anything of interest-- the
square is on the right,
the square is on the left.
They had n only a minuscule
fraction of the processing
speed and a vanishingly
small amount of memory
in which to store data
compared to today's computers.
But most importantly,
there simply
weren't many sources
of machine readable
data available to learn from.
What were you going to learn?
For real time learning, most
communication at that time
was on paper.
And for real-time learning,
the data from sensors
was equally primitive and
only available, usually,
in an analog form that really
resisted processing digitally.
So you had four
trends-- improvement
in computing speed,
memory, the transition
from physical to electronically
stored data, and easier access
to large bodies of data.
God knows you guys
know about that.
It's mainly due to the internet
and low-cost, high-resolution
digital sensors.
I don't know how I came up
with five, but I can't count.
These were the prime
drivers-- never
give a talk the first time.
These were prime drivers in
the refocusing of efforts
from the symbolic reasoning
approach to the machine
learning approach.
OK, there's a little
bit of history for you.
Now let me get to
the main issue.
Can machines think?
So what is artificial
intelligence, really?
After a lifetime of
work in this field
and a great deal of
reflection on this question,
my reluctant and disappointing
answer is simple.
No.
Or at least they can't
think the way people think.
So far, at least, there's no
obvious road map from here
to there.
Machines are not people.
And there's simply no
persuasive argument
that they're on the
same path to becoming
generally intelligent,
sentient beings,
despite what you
see in the movies.
Now, wait a minute,
you might say.
Jerry, can't they solve all
sorts of complex reasoning
and perception problems?
Sure they can.
They can perform
tasks that humans
solve using intelligence.
But that doesn't mean that
the machines are intelligent.
It merely means that many
tasks that we thought
required general intelligence
are in fact subject to solution
by other kinds of
mechanical means.
Now, there's an old
joke in AI, which
is that once an AI problem
is solved, it's no longer AI.
Anybody heard that?
A couple of people, good.
Now, personally, I don't think
that's any longer a joke.
I'm going to look at
some of the signature
accomplishments of
artificial intelligence
from this different perspective.
Let's start with computer chess.
Now, for decades--
most of you guys
weren't around to
see this, but I
was-- the archetypal test
of the coming of age of AI
wasn't the Turing test.
It was, could a
machine ever beat
the world's chess champion?
For a long time,
you see, chess was
considered the
quintessential demonstration
of human intelligence.
So surely when a computer
was world chess champion,
AI would have arrived.
That's it.
We'd have smart machines.
Well, it happened in
1997 when IBM's Deep Blue
beat the then champion,
Garry Kasparov.
Lots of ink was spilled in the
media lamenting the arrival
of super-intelligent machines.
There was a lot of hand
wringing or what this meant
for the future of mankind.
But the truth is it meant
nothing other than that you
could do a lot of
clever programming
and use the increases in speed
of computers to play chess.
The techniques used
have applications
to similar classes of problems.
But they hardly proved to be
the harbingers of the robot
apocalypse.
So let me tell you
what people said
after that non-event happened.
They said, OK, sure,
computers can play chess.
But they'll never be
able to drive a car.
This really was what happened.
That requires a
broad understanding
of the real world-- the ability
to make split-second judgments
in chaotic circumstances.
And, of course, common sense--
machines will never have that.
Well, as you know, this
bulwark of human supremacy
was breached in 2004
with the DARPA Grand
Challenge for
autonomous vehicles,
which are soon coming,
if they're not here,
to a parking lot near you.
How many of you guys
have taken a ride
in the Google self-driving cars?
What?
Oh, they should
send one up here.
Have you been at least down
to the Tesla dealership
to take a test drive?
I did that over the weekend.
The self-driving car was cool.
OK, now our self-driving
cars do just that.
They drive cars.
They don't build houses.
They don't cook meals.
They don't make beds.
That's what they do.
So computers can play
chess and drive cars.
But then they
said-- people said,
but they could
never play Jeopardy.
OK, well, that requires
too much world knowledge
and understanding metaphors
and clever wordplay.
Well, thanks again to be
ingenious people at IBM,
this hurdle has
also been cleared.
As undoubtedly you know,
IBM's Watson system
beat Ken Jennings, the world
Jeopardy champion in 2011.
Now, what is Watson?
The reality is it's a collection
of facts and figures encoded
into cleverly
organized modules that
can quickly and
accurately answer
various types of common
Jeopardy questions.
Watson's main advantage
over the human contestants,
believe it or not, was
that it could ring in
before they could when it
estimated a high likelihood
that it had a correct answer.
I would love to go in this
in more detail for you.
It turns out most of
the Jeopardy champions
know the answers.
They're just not that fast.
And so the machine had
numerous advantages.
It's a long-- it was
kind of a magic show.
It's a wonderful accomplishment.
It's a really remarkable
and very sophisticated
knowledge-based retrieval
system and an inference system
that was honed, at
least at that time,
to a particular problem set.
Now they're trying to
apply it to lots of others.
Now, how many of you saw
that, or pictures of it?
OK, now here's what bothers me.
Is this supposed to be animated?
OK.
Now, in my opinion, IBM
didn't do the field of AI
any favors by wrapping
Watson in a theatrical suite
of anthropomorphic features.
There's really no
technical reason
to have a system say its
responses in a calm, didactic
tone of voice.
Yes, Alex, the answer
is such and such.
Much less to put up a head-like
graphic of swirling lights,
suggesting that the
machine had a mind
and was thinking
about the problem.
These were incidental adornments
to a tremendous technical
achievement.
Now, without a
deep understanding
of how these systems
work, and with humans
as the only available
exemplars with which
to interpret the
results, the temptation
to view them as human-like
is really irresistible.
But they aren't those things.
OK, so let me give you a couple
more interesting examples--
more contemporary, things
that you're probably
more familiar with.
What about these machine
learning systems?
Aren't they more like
human intelligence?
Well, not really.
True, I could argue
this for two hours here.
Lots of people
sticking their hand up.
In reality, the use of the
term neural networks is
little more than an analogy,
in the same sense as saying
airplane design was
inspired by birds.
It's in the same category.
Consider how machines
and people learn.
You can teach a computer
to recognize cats
by showing it a million images.
You guys know Andrew Ng?
He was at Google when
he did that work.
You can show it
a million images,
or you could simply point
one out to a three-year-old
and get the same job done.
That's a cat.
Oh, that's it.
Now, from then on, the three
year old knows what a cat is.
Obviously, humans and machines
do not learn the same way.
And let me give you another
interesting example.
Anybody here doing
machine translation?
One Google site.
OK, I'm going into the lion's
den in about two weeks.
I'm going to talk to the
machine translation people,
among others.
Now, tremendous
strides have been
made in this field
in the past few years
mainly by applying statistical
and machine learning
techniques to large
bodies of concordant text.
But how do people perform
this difficult task?
Think about how people do it.
They learn two or
more languages,
along with the respective
cultures and conventions.
Then they read some
text in one language,
they understand what it says,
and they render the meaning
as closely as possible
in another language.
Now, machine translation, as
successful as it is today,
there's no relationship to
the human translation process.
Its success simply means
there's another way
to approximate the same results.
It's mostly just
concordances of text.
It doesn't relate to the way
people solve that problem.
What do we learn from this?
It's just a way
to-- we just didn't
think there was another
solution, but there is,
besides having people
understand that.
Now, let me go on to one
you are all carrying around.
You carry around smartphones.
They're reminiscent
of the capabilities
of the computer on the Star
Trek Enterprise-- "Star Trek?"
Everybody?
Good, OK.
I started talking
about "The Jetsons"
in my class at Stanford, nobody
knew what I was talking about.
What's that?
You know, Rosie
and-- you know, OK.
That's called getting old.
So this is more like--
I lost complete track,
and I got the whole thing
right in front of me.
Hey, Siri, you know?
You can talk to your
phone, and it talks back.
It also becomes more
capable every day
as you download new apps and
upgrade the operating system.
So I'm using examples
of [INAUDIBLE].
But do you really
think of your phone
as getting smarter
in the human sense
when you download an app or
you enable voice recognition?
Certainly not in the
same sense that you
get smarter when
you learn calculus
or when you learn philosophy.
It's the electronic equivalent
of a Swiss Army knife.
It's a bunch of different
information processing tools
that are bound together
into a single unit,
taking advantage of some
commonalities, like detailed
maps, and like internet access.
Now, you have one
integrated mind,
while your phone
has no mind at all.
There's no one home.
So I try to make the case
that machines perform
an increasingly
diverse array of tasks
that people perform by applying
their native intelligence.
Now, does that mean
that machines are smart?
Well, now things
get interesting.
Let's talk about how you
might measure supposed machine
intelligence.
I pulled that picture
off the internet.
So I didn't make it up.
That's part of the point
I'm trying to make.
We can start by looking at how
we measure human intelligence.
Now, a common method is with
IQ tests, but even for humans,
this is a deeply flawed concept.
We love to measure and
rank things with numbers.
But let's face it,
reducing human intelligence
to a flat, linear scale
is highly questionable.
Little Sally did two more
arithmetic problems than Johnny
did in time allotted, so her
IQ is seven points higher
than his.
Bull.
But that's not to say that
some people aren't smarter
than others-- only that simple
numerical measures provide
an inappropriate patina of
objectivity and precision.
As psychologists are
fond of pointing out,
there are many different
kinds of intelligence.
There's social and emotional,
analytic, athletic, musical, et
cetera.
But what on Earth does it mean
to say that Mozart and Einstein
have the same IQ?
Now, suppose we gave
the same intelligence
tests to a machine.
Wow!
And it only took one millisecond
to accurately complete
all of the sums that took
Sally, and Johnny, and Alan.
It must be super-smart.
It also outperforms all
humans on memory tests,
logical reasoning tests,
and god knows what else.
Maybe it can shoot
straighter, read faster,
and can outrun
the fastest human.
Oh my god.
Robots can outperform us.
What are we all going to do?
So are the robots taking over?
Are the robots taking over?
Of course, by the
logic I just gave you,
machines took over a long time
ago whether they are smart
or not.
They move our freight.
They score our tests.
They explore the cosmos.
They plant and pick
most of our crops.
They trade stocks.
They store and retrieve our
documents, as Jacob knows,
in petabytes.
They manufacture just
about everything,
including themselves.
And sometimes they do
it with human help,
and sometimes without
human intervention.
And yet, they aren't
taking over our businesses.
They aren't marrying
our children.
They are not watching the SyFy
channel when we're not around.
So what's wrong with the
traditional picture of AI?
We can build machines and
write programs and perform
tasks that previously
required human intelligence
and attention, but there's
really nothing new about that.
Each new technological
breakthrough
from the invention of
the plow to to the CGI
rendering of Rapunzel's
hair is better
understood as an
advance in automation,
not as a usurpation
of human primacy.
We can program machines to
solve very complex problems,
and they may operate with
increasing independence.
But as a friend of
mine once observed,
a vehicle will
really be autonomous
when you instruct it to
take you to the office,
and it decides to go
to the beach instead.
My point is simple.
Lots of problems we think
require human intelligence
to solve actually don't.
There are lots of other
ways to solve them,
and that's what the
machines are doing.
Calculating used
to be the province
of highly trained specialists.
Did you guys know that?
You used to go see
somebody when you
wanted to do some calculation.
Now all it takes is
the $0.99 calculator.
Making money in the
stock market used
to be the province of experts.
Now the majority of trading
is initiated by computers.
It's the same for driving
directions, picking and packing
orders in warehouses, and
designing more efficient wings
for airplanes.
But you don't have to worry
about the robots taking over.
Robots don't have feelings,
except in the movies.
Here's a news flash for you.
They aren't male or female.
As I like to say to
my Stanford students,
what does it mean for
a robot to be gay?
So robots don't have
independent goals and desires.
A robot that's designed
to wash and fold laundry
isn't going to wake up one day
and say, oh my god, what a fool
I've been.
I really want to play the
great concert halls of Europe.
So just as we can teach
bears to ride bikes,
and we can teach chimps
to use sign language,
we could build
machines to perform
tasks the way
people do, and even
to simulate human emotions.
We can make them say ouch
when you pinch them or wag
their tails when you pet them.
But there's simply
no compelling reason
to believe this bears any
meaningful relationship
to human behavior or experience.
Machines aren't
people, even if we
build them to talk and walk and
chew gum the way that we do.
OK, now I've given
you a new way to think
about artificial intelligence.
Let's talk about
the implications
of this new perspective.
I'm going to try
to run through this
pretty quickly because
I was warned people like
to ask questions.
Now, it's certainly
true that AI is
going to have a
serious impact on labor
markets and employment.
But perhaps not in the
way that people expect.
If you think of machines as
becoming even more intelligent
and threatening our livelihoods,
the obvious solution
is to prevent them from getting
smarter, and to lock our doors
and arm ourselves with Tasers
against these robots that
are coming to take our jobs.
Well, the robots are coming,
but not exactly for our jobs.
Machines and computers
don't perform jobs.
They automate tasks.
Now, except in extreme cases,
you don't roll in a robot
and show an employee
to the door.
Instead, the new technologies
hollow out and change the jobs
that people perform.
Even experts spend most
of their time doing
mundane, repetitive tasks.
They review lab tests.
They draft simple contracts.
They write straightforward
press releases.
They fill out
paperwork and forms.
On the blue collar
side, lots of workers
lay bricks, paint houses, mow
lawns, drive cars, load trucks,
pack boxes, and
take blood samples.
They fight fires, deliver
direct traffic, et cetera.
And many of these intellectual
and physical tasks
require straightforward logic
or simple hand-eye coordination.
Now, the new technologies,
mainly driven
by artificial intelligence, are
poised to automate these tasks,
not to replace the jobs.
Now, if your job involves
a narrow, well-defined set
of duties, and many
do, then indeed,
your employment is at risk.
If you have a broader
set of responsibilities,
or if your job requires a
human touch such as expressing
sympathy or providing
companionship,
I don't think you have
too much to worry about.
Now, just check
out this comparison
of the job duties between
licensed practical nurses
and bricklayers.
Whose job do you think is
most at risk from automation?
By the way, this
list is hilarious.
"Monitoring fluid and
food intake and output."
I was like, OK, I didn't
know they measure output.
"Providing emotional support."
What you guys are working
on-- (ROBOT VOICE)
I am so sorry
about your problem.
I mean, come on.
Most jobs, as opposed
to tasks, involve
a mix of general capabilities
and specific skills.
And as machines perform
the more routine tasks,
the plain fact is
that fewer people are
needed to get the jobs done.
So one person's
productivity enhancing tool
is in fact another's pink
slip, or more likely,
a job opening that no
longer needs to be filled.
Now, this is called
structural unemployment.
Automation, whether it's driven
by artificial intelligence
or not, it changes
the skills that
are necessary to perform work.
I need to move ahead, because
we're running out of time.
So this is called
structural unemployment,
and it's the mismatch of skills
against the needs of employers.
People get put out of
work because it's not
so much that there's
a lack of jobs,
but the training that people
need to perform those jobs--
there's a disconnect.
Now, historically, as
automation has eliminated
the need for workers, the
resulting increase in wealth
has eventually generated
new kinds of jobs
to take up the slack.
And I see no reason that pattern
is not going to continue,
but the keyword
there is eventually.
Let's talk about
farm employment.
This stuff is amazing,
if you look into it.
200 years ago, more than
90% of the US population
worked in agriculture.
Basically, almost all anyone
did was grow and prepare food.
That's what it meant to work.
Now, today, less than
2% of the population
is required to feed
everybody, as you can
see in the free food over here.
Oh my god, is
everybody out of work?
Of course not.
We've had plenty
of time to adapt,
and as our standard of living
has relentlessly increased,
which I'll get to in a
minute, new opportunities
have always arisen for
people to fill the expanding
expectations of our ever
richer and greedier society.
Now, if a person from
1800 could see us today,
they'd think we'd all gone nuts.
Why not work a few hours a
week, buy a sack of potatoes
and a jug of wine , build
a shack in the woods,
dig a hole for an outhouse,
and live a life of leisure?
Somehow, our rising
expectations seem
to be magically out of
pace due to our wealth.
OK, so what are the
jobs of the future?
I don't see why we can't be a
society of competitive gamers,
artisans, personal shoppers,
flower arrangers, tennis pros,
party planners,
and no doubt a lot
of other things that
don't exist yet.
You might say, well, who is
going to do the real work?
Well, our great
grandchildren may
think of our idea of real
work as so 21st century.
It may take, as we think of
with agriculture-- it may only
take 2% of the population,
assisted by some pretty
remarkable automation,
to accomplish what's
taking 90% of our labor today.
So what?
It may be as important
to them to have
fresh flowers in
the house each day
as it is for us to take
a shower every day,
which 70% of the
US population does.
By the way, in 1900, the
average was once a week.
I'm glad I'm not there.
So let me move ahead.
That's the good news.
The bad news is it
it's going to take time
for this transition to happen.
And there's a new wave of AI
enabled applications that's
likely to accelerate the
normal cycle of job creation
and destruction.
So we're going to
need to find new ways
to retrain displaced workers.
I was going to go into this.
I know Jacob's
interested in this,
but hopefully, we're going to
have to skip over this idea.
Our problem is our
vocational training system
is really messed up.
It's mainly because the
government today is the lender
of first resort for students.
So the skills that
people learn are
disconnected from the
needs of the employers
in the marketplace.
So we're not actually
investing in education
so much as we're
heading out money
to people to learn things that
won't help them pay it back.
You can't get a job?
It's too bad.
Your student loan is still due.
How many of you guys
have student loans?
OK, not bad.
So there are different
ways to do this,
and we need to create
new financial instruments
that tie the
development of capital,
the deployment of capital, to
the return on the investment.
And I've got this
concept that I talk
about in my book, which
is somewhere around here,
that I call a job mortgage.
So you get a mortgage
for your education,
and it is payable solely out
of your future earnings stream.
And that causes all
the right incentives
to align so that we're teaching
people the right things.
Otherwise, people aren't
going to give them
the money if they don't know
that there's going to be
a likelihood of a payback.
Finally, there's one
other dark cloud.
I painted a very optimistic
view of the future.
While it's true that automation
makes a society richer,
there are serious questions
about whose pockets
are filled by that wealth.
You may be aware while
we were on high tech,
we tend to believe
we are developing
dazzling technologies for
a needy and grateful world,
and indeed, we've
made great progress
in raising the standard
of living for the poorest
people on Earth.
But for the developed world,
the news is not so good.
Up until about 1970,
on and off, we've
found ways to
distribute at least some
of those economic
benefits across society,
and this was the rise in the
supposed-- the mythical middle
class.
But it doesn't take much to
see that those days are over.
They began to diverge.
So as economists
know, automation
is the substitute of
capital for labor.
And Karl Marx was right.
The struggle between
capital and labor
is a losing proposition
for workers.
What that means is that
the benefits of automation
naturally accrue to those who
can invest in the new systems.
And why not?
People aren't really working
harder than they used to work.
In fact, they aren't really
smarter than they used to be.
Working hours have
actually decreased
slowly but consistently for
about the last 100 years.
The reason we can
do more with less
is that the business owners
invest some of their capital
into the process and
productivity for improvements.
And they reap the
most of the rewards.
So what has all this
got to do with AI?
Now, the technologies
that are on the drawing
boards in our labs are
quickening the hearts
of entrepreneurs and
investors everywhere,
as you guys are well aware.
And they are the ones
who stand to benefit
while they export more
and more of the risk out
to the rest of society.
Workers are less secure today.
Wages are stagnant.
Pension funds can go bust.
We're raising a
generation of contractors
for the gig economy.
They're working variable
hours, and health benefits
are their own problem.
That's not true for you guys.
You have regular
employment jobs.
But if you really
find out what's
going on in the rest of
the world, this is true.
Now, some people have
the mistaken impression
that the free market
will naturally
address these problems if only
we can get the government out
of the way.
And I'm here to tell you
that our economy is hardly
an example of
unfettered capitalism.
The fact is that there are all
sorts of rules and policies
that drive where the capital
goes, how it's deployed,
and who gets the returns.
And the basic problem
is-- ah, this is great.
I should show the slides
while I give the talk.
The basic problem is that
our economic and regulatory
policies have become decoupled
from our social goals.
And we have to fix that.
But the question is how?
Now here's the good news.
Most people have
no idea about this.
The good news is that
the economy isn't static.
It doubles about every 40 years.
You guys are familiar with the
singularity and the Moore's
curve and all that.
That's happening
with the economy too,
not just with computers.
It doubles about every 40 years,
and it's done that reliably
since the start
of the Industrial
Revolution in the 1700s.
In 1800, the average
household income was $1,000.
And that's about
the same as it is
today in Malawi and Mozambique.
And probably not
coincidentally, their economies
look surprisingly similar to
what the US was 200 years ago.
Yet I doubt that people
in Ben Franklin's time
thought of themselves
as dirt poor--
that they were barely
scratching out an existence.
So what this means is that 40
years from now, most likely
there's literally going
to be twice as much wealth
to go around.
So the challenge for us
is to implement policies
that will encourage that wealth
to be more broadly distributed.
We don't have to take from
the rich and give to the poor.
We need to provide
incentives for entrepreneurs
and businesses to
find ways to benefit
ever larger swaths of society.
So in my book, again,
I just give you
an example of the
kinds of policies
that smart folks like
you could come up with.
And the idea here is to make
corporate taxes progressive.
I'm not saying this is the
answer or even an answer.
It's just the kind of
thinking we need to do.
You can make corporate
taxes progressive
based on how widely distributed
the equity in a company is.
So companies that have
larger stockholder bases
have a lower tax rate.
Microsoft, to use
them as an example,
they should pay a
far lower tax rate
than Bechtel, which
is privately held.
Now, progressive
policies like this,
to promote our social
goals-- by the way,
I flesh that out in the book
in quite a bit of detail,
how it would work, and I
encourage to you to buy a copy,
if not read one.
Progressive policies like that
can promote our social goals
without stifling the economy.
We just have to get on with
it and stop believing the myth
that unfettered capitalism
is the answer to the world's
problems.
So let me wrap
things up and recap.
I don't want you to
think I'm anti-AI.
Nothing's further
from the truth.
I think the potential
impact on world is similar,
and I'm not exaggerating
this-- the potential impact is
about the same as the
invention of the wheel.
We need to think of
it not of some sort
of magical discontinuity in the
development of intelligent life
on earth, but as a powerful
collection of automation tools
with the potential to
transform our livelihoods
and to vastly
increase our wealth.
The challenge we face is that
our existing institutions,
without some
enlightened rethinking,
run a serious risk of making
a mess of this opportunity.
I'm supremely confident
that our future
is very bright--
that it it's more
"Star Trek" than "Terminator."
But the transition is going
to be protracted and brutal
unless we pay
attention to the issues
that I tried to raise
with you here today.
We have to find
new and better ways
to ensure that our
economy doesn't motor on,
going faster and faster, while
throwing ever more people
overboard.
Our technology and our
economy should serve us, not
the other way around.
So thank you.
I'm sorry to run so long.
Next time I give the talk,
it would be half this long.
[APPLAUSE]
Do we have time for questions?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, so we
do have a little bit of time
for questions.
There is a mic placed
right over there
for those who want to ask
questions, please line up.
You guys need to do that.
Go for it.
AUDIENCE: So for the task
of taking over the world,
are there other means except
for having human intelligence?
JERRY KAPLAN: Yeah, it's
a very dangerous issue,
as a matter of fact, because
a lot of the AI technologies,
we talk about the
productivity and all of that.
But they have very serious
applications in, for example,
military use.
And this is a very
difficult problem.
A lot of very smart
people are actually--
I wouldn't say secretly,
but not publicly working on.
A friend of mine is on his
way to Geneva right now.
There's meetings
regularly with the UN.
There's a lot going
on in the US military,
because they recognize that just
going ahead and implementing
the kinds of technologies to the
battlefield that are currently
being applied to driving
cars and other things
might backfire, because
it would be a lot easier
for non-state actors,
to put it politely,
and dictators to-- today it
takes enormous investment
to make and buy bombers
and all that kind of stuff.
It's going to be really cheap,
just like everything else,
like cellphones.
And there are some
really creepy things
that can be done to
take over the world
and wipe out humanity
at a very low cost,
and that's going to
be a big problem.
AUDIENCE: So you gave a
lot of examples of problems
that we thought that
were innately human,
but we were later able to
describe it in a different way.
So why should we doubt
that unbounded learning
is a problem we can't
describe in a different way?
By unbounded learning,
I mean the example
you gave-- oh, that's a cat.
Or for humans, you know,
if you ask them, pass me
the purple cup, they'll
learn that's purple
if they didn't know that word.
Why can't that unbounded
learning be described in a way
that we can train machines
to learn in the same way
that babies learn?
JERRY KAPLAN: Well, I'm
going to turn your question
around a little bit to put
it in the context of what
I said here.
I'm not saying that any
particular task is completely
impervious to machine learning.
In fact, it might very well be.
However, machine
learning is really
good at picking out patterns
in large volumes of data
as it's practiced today.
It could be a future form of
software technology, which
could do something more
into what you said,
but that doesn't mean that they
have human-like characteristics
or human learning.
And it doesn't mean
that all of our jobs
will go away because
a lot of our jobs
require face-to-face interaction
or the expression of empathy.
And I don't buy the idea
that machines can effectively
express empathy in their
dealings with other people.
So the tasks can go
away, and maybe they
will be able to learn as well.
That would be great.
That's a cat.
That's a chair.
That's that-- boom, boom,
boom, the machine's got it.
But that's just another step
in a long line of things
where people looked,
and they went, wow!
It used to take
people to do that.
Now a machine can do it.
It's just the next step.
So a lot of that stuff
is going to go away.
And if we all wind
up-- nobody wants
to watch a robot play
competitive tennis.
It's just not interesting.
So I mean, there are lots of
these jobs that inherently
require human beings.
So I'm trying to separate
the task of automation
from what will people do.
And I hope that began--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I guess it was
even just the empathy example.
You say that robots can't be
empathetic, but maybe they can.
Maybe we just think that's
an innately human thing.
The tennis example actually
is very convincing to me,
like, I would never watch
a robot play tennis.
But if a robot was
just as empathetic
and had a human form,
and you couldn't
tell that it was a robot when
you walked into the doctor.
We think it's a human
problem, but maybe it's not.
JERRY KAPLAN: Boy, this is
a really complicated topic.
What you said is right.
We can fool people.
And we do this all the time.
We can build a way-- this has
gone on since the 16th century,
where they built automatons.
We went, oh, my god,
it's just like a person.
And they were amazing.
Have you ever seen these?
These mechanical devices are
absolutely incredible-- 16th
and 17th century.
It was fun entertainment
for the courts of kings.
But if you know it's a machine,
the fact that the screen comes
up and says, thank you,
I really appreciate
that you placed your order.
I mean, come on.
It just doesn't
compute emotionally.
We're not going
to buy that story.
So a lot of it has to do with,
like, toys that look like dogs
or look like children or play.
It's all very complicated,
because play--
if you're doing it knowingly,
that's perfectly reasonable.
If you're doing play because
you're being fooled, or being
persuaded to buy something
because the machine has gone,
oh, come on.
I got a whole bunch of
hungry mouths to feed.
Oh, please, buy this car for me.
We're not going to like that.
That's my point.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JERRY KAPLAN: Thanks.
Yes, sir.
No waiting on check stand 2.
AUDIENCE: So I agreed with
most everything you said.
I had a problem with
one of your examples,
and this may seem
like a nitpick.
But I'm going to
flip this around.
You said teaching a machine
a new task was like teaching
a primate to use sign language.
So do you think primates
don't use intelligence the way
we do and don't understand
what's being said?
JERRY KAPLAN:
That's a good point.
I think that the point
I was trying to make
is different than the one
that you-- I'm not saying I
didn't say what you said, but
that's not really what I meant.
What I meant was you
can take something
that has no natural affinity
for that particular task,
and you can get
it to do that task
to some level of competence.
That's what I was trying to say.
Your point about chimp
stuff is pretty interesting,
because obviously
they have brains.
And I think most
reasonable people think
they have rudimentary minds.
But the point is they don't
naturally use sign language,
and as I say, you teach
a bear to ride a bike.
That's not like, oh, my god,
what are we going to do?
Next thing you know we'll be
teaching bears to drive cars.
It's that we can make machines
that also appear human-like
and do these
human-like activities,
but it's not a natural
part of the process.
Machines have certain
characteristics,
and I can give another
talk on that subject.
What are those characters ?
And they're different
than people,
and we need to
understand that and stop
thinking about ourselves as
we're making more and more
intelligent machines.
I'm just giving you
the framing to help
us to understand the economic
results that are appropriate.
Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: If
we go quickly, we
have time for two
more questions.
JERRY KAPLAN: Two more, OK.
AUDIENCE: You were talking a
bit about the social impacts,
and in the end, the people
who own the machines
get the benefit
from the machines.
And I agreed there when
you talked about ways
to change policy,
but historically,
social-focused
policies have come
from things like labor
movements-- people
controlling the means of
production or whatever.
These kinds of things
where people go on strike.
Who is going to strike if
all the people doing tasks
have just been replaced?
I own a machine.
I don't have any workers, right?
I got a factory that
builds everything I need,
and I try to sell it to people.
And eventually it might
implode, I don't know,
if everybody is doing it.
But the remaining
jobs are really
just kind of these neat,
supervisory things or the 1%
of the population that can
get a big audience on whatever
medium.
How do you run a whole
economy based on that?
JERRY KAPLAN: Well, there are
two basic points you're making.
Let me try to respond
to them each briefly.
Because you're right
in a lot of senses.
When you automate people
out of jobs, for those jobs,
we don't need people.
And the question is
when are the new jobs
going to arrive, if ever?
Most people are thinking
about this statically,
like, well, we're just going to
automate away 90% of the jobs
when we can build
machines that dig ditches
and do all that kind of stuff.
But I think historically
what happens
is new jobs are created
that require humans
for one reason or another.
And I tried to kind
of make that point.
We really can be
a leisure society.
What we would think of
as a leisure society,
that's what you'll get
paid for in the future.
In 80 years, the average
American, if these trends hold,
the average American
household would
be making $200,000 a year.
Now, most of you guys make
$200,000 a year, I understand.
It pays well here, and
I was making a joke.
But my point about
that is that there
are going to be
people-- when you're
making that kind of money,
you want those fresh flowers
every day, and you may be
willing to pay somebody
to do that and pay them
a living wage to do it.
So I think the nature of
work is going to shift.
Those people from 1800 who
look at us today and think
we're crazy because
we are we're doing
stuff we don't need to do for
people who don't need it done.
And that is the way
they would look at it.
And I can't say for sure,
but I think that pattern
is likely to continue.
It's just very hard to
visualize what that's
going to be like in 80 years.
AUDIENCE: My question
is when do you
think AI will get
to the point where
it can predict the behavior
of other AI actors?
Because I think that's the
heart of human intelligence
in the social context,
and we haven't really
seen much in that task space.
JERRY KAPLAN: Wow, again,
a very complicated-- I
could go on for a
long time on this.
This has come up already
in things like the flash
crash of 2010, which I cover
in my book, which you're all
encouraged to take a look at.
It's a real problem,
because people are stealthy
developing these
systems, and it creates
what's called systemic risk.
Because these machines are like
gods in terms of the damage
they can inflict
in milliseconds.
And so it shut down
the US power grid.
You can bet that China today,
or I shouldn't pick out
China-- powerful players
today have the ability
to completely decimate our
economy for a fair period
of time almost instantly--
almost like a press
of a button.
And so these are
difficult issues,
because you get two of those.
You ever seen the old movie
"Colossus-- The Forbin
Project"?
Anybody?
So one guy, two guys will
know what I'm talking about.
It's about just that.
They created an
intelligent system.
The Russians-- this was like
1960 when they made the film,
it was great-- also did that.
And the two of them figured
there had to be another one,
and they got together, and
they took over the world.
It's actually a
pretty cool film.
It's not as stupid as it sounds.
So it's a real issue.
These side effects,
the unintended
consequences-- the
kinds of technology
we're developing-- that's
another hour-long talk.
It doesn't mean we
shouldn't do it.
It means we need
to be aware of it
to figure out how to control
it in reasonable ways.
So I apologize [INAUDIBLE].
If anybody wants to stay and
hear stories about early Google
like I would-- well here he is.
I won't do it on camera
because I don't want anybody
to record it.
But thank you.
Thank you so much for
listening to my crazy rants.
[APPLAUSE]